وزي السماوات
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد
يقول الحافظ النووي رحمه الله تعالى في
كتابه رياض الصالحين في باب فضل الجمعه
في باب فضل يوم الجمعه وعن ابي هريره رضي
الله عنه
ان رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
من اغتسل يوم الجمعه غسل الجنابه ثم راح
في الساعه الاولى فكانما قرب بدنه ومن راح
في الساعه الثانيه فكانما قرب بقره ومن
راح في الساعه الثالثه فكانما قرب كبشا
اقرن ومن راح في الساعه الرابعه فكانما
قرب دجاجه ومن راح في الساعه الخامسه
فكانما قرب بيضه فاذا خرج الامام امام
حضرت الملائكه يستمعون الذكرى متفق عليه
قوله غسل الجنابه اي غسلا كغسل الجنابه في
الصفه
رياض الصالحين
جمعه
جمعهميره
رضي الله عنهourلاه
الجمعه
more
ابو هريره رضي الله
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
جمعه
would
جناب
‏and
out first
is as if
made
ofel
now
this statement of first hour and second
hour and third hour andth hour how do we
how do we judge how many hours this is
how do we understand
الفقهاء رحمهم الله
فجر
‏sunrise
this is
hour
we would take
from that so about 10 to 15 minut after
sunrise until the
stands on the
that time that is between when the sun
rises above the horizon until the stands
on the to give
السلام عليكم
any
after that this is not
this
of forgiveness of what is between every
‏et
before
on the additional
virtues and rewards they are no longer
available at that point and so the
time between when the sun rises
until the gets on the m that time in
between whether it's 6 hours or
‏each of these is what this narration is
speaking about whether 4 hours
8 hours whatever that time is that chunk
of time we would divide it into six
equal portions and whoever arrives in
the first sixth of that those hour those
times
then it is as ‏If he has sacrificed a
camel, he will have the same reward, the
same complete reward of sacrificing a
camel. How much does a camel cost and
how much does it cost to sacrifice one?
It's incredibly expensive.
ومن راح في الساعه الثانيه فكانما قرب
بقره
ومن راح في الساعه الثالثه فكانما قرب
كبشا اقرا
ومن راح في الساعه الرابعه
فكانما قرب دجاجه
ومن راح في الساعه الخامسه فكانما قرب
بيضه
فاذا خرج الامام حضرت الملائكه يستمعون
الذكرم
anger
‏anger into
here
للصلاه من يوم الجمعه
فاسعوا الى ذكر الله
وذا البيع الله سبحانه وتعالى
صلاه الجمعه
جمعه
الله
صلى الله عليه
يستمعون الذكر
الله سبحانه وتعالى
خطبه
opses
entment
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ركعه جمعه
خطبه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏otherobحه
وى خطبه الذكر
احط
خطبه
isلام
which are to be
minut topicsil
topics
points it is supposed to في صلب المسائل
الشرعيه
سنه
tols
educated
with
[Silence]
‏prop
‏under the majority
of
topics and
day to life and even
life
نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان يجعلنا ممن
يستمعون القول فيتبعون احسنه وان يبارك
لنا في هذا اليوم وهذا المسجد المبارك
نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان يجعلنا ممن يسعون
الى ذكر الله ويذرون البيعه ويقول ويقومون
باوامر الله وينتهون عن نواهيه والله اعلم
وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد